I can't tell you how good it is to see
both of your faces you guys it's so
great to see you so how have you been
doing where where are you guys right now
we are currently in LA at my house yeah
I don't really I mean you you can't you
can't man so you're they're very
elaborate camera setup just got attacked
by the cat I'm a kitty this is these are
the technical issues that we deal with
in that run the rumble was not an
earthquake it was turkey ah it's what's
your name turkey jerky ninja star cool
nickname he likes a ninja turtle Matt
help
how much has a ninja turtle been helping
you guys cope with what's been going on
the last you know couple months oh so
much so I think we'll just needs love
he's so simple he just wants love and I
think it's a constant reminder that if
you got snuggles everything's gonna be
but you hasn't been doing okay have you
been it's a great time to be creative
have you been creating a lot right now I
think in the beginning of quarantine we
were being as creative you know I think
I think we were putting pressure on
ourselves in the beginning it were just
like why
and lately exact we've been way more
creative just you know dragging a little
bit more just trying to be like oh just
like slightly more production yeah we
just got word that we caught a wave and
they just wrote a bunch of songs were
like yeah as it seems like it's been a
nice time for you guys to spend together
it has it's been like a test of your
relationship and how much time you can
spend in close quarters together easiest
we're thriving like it's because I know
that so much so many bad things are
happening in the world I know but if the
world was going on the way that it
usually does he would be on tour and I
would never see him so then we're
getting placed so much Scrabble oh my
god she beat me to the very first time
it was a big
yeah she like so we got into Scrabble I
won the first few games she was she had
never played before so she's forgiven
but this one has a way with words and
then she figured it out and then she
asked Julia how is he with defeat how is
he in loss lovely he's very supportive
and then he comes back he's like I'm
never letting you marry good that's my
JP was recently in studio with us I want
to say it was what two three months ago
something like that yeah and yeah and
you were you know we were talking all
about the song and you're telling us the
story of how you guys clicked and so now
it's Julia's turn now Julia got to tell
her version of the story of how you guys
clicked and when was that moment that
you knew you're like this guy it's this
guy that did happen and then we had our
first date the next day and I never met
anybody that could psychoanalyze me just
as well as I could psychoanalyze
somebody else and I was like oh you see
me and that's scary and I like it we
were officially a couple eight days
later and now I get to know every day
some ways and every day and I get to
know just how silly and goofy is and I
think the best friend about our
relationship as we just make each other
laugh all the time
we're very door each the cycle analysis
is there but like it's mixed in with
just complete silliness wonderful human
the fact that the first thing you wanted
to share with me was that you've been
playing lots of Scrabble it's very
telling I love that so many facts the
this song because I I want to talk about
the song a bit and
for a lot of reasons because number one
when news started going around that we
were gonna have to start locking down
that people's eyes are going to have to
start changing we you and I JP had not
talked he we had talked like a little
bit before that but the song kept
playing in my head over and over it just
Tamiya was like wow
like this is in a way this is kind of
what's happening and I've been seeing
people online the song has been sort of
a soundtrack for their if they were by
themself like sitting at their window
longing for someone or something and not
that a song didn't have so much more
meaning before but what does it mean now
well I take this one together so when we
first wrote the song it was inspired by
the earthquakes in Los Angeles in this
hypothetical catastrophe that you would
imagine just making anything that got in
the way of love seemed irrelevant we did
not anticipate obviously six or
someone's later there being a very real
catastrophe that would make it not so
hypothetical to be imagining who you
would want to be with in a moment like
this so I think originally the song is
inspired by wanting to put love before
everything else and I think that's why
it's resonating right now because more
than ever love feels like it needs to
come before and everything just like we
talked about with ninja turtle and it's
been beautiful to see the song take on
different meanings like we did a version
of the song to raise money for Doctors
Without Borders
and you know I got a message from a
friend who works with Doctors Without
Borders saying that when they finally
thought a group of doctors into Iraq
they were listening to if the world was
ending as the plane landed because they
felt it resonated with the idea that in
the most dire of circumstances they will
they will be the people that will always
come over and the fact that the song
could take on a prime meaning is so so
special so special
mm-hmm and with with everybody
championing so many causes that help
others right now Doctors Without Borders
is always an important one but what was
it specific
about the organization that you wanted
to put your your art and your talent and
your love behind one of my really close
friends works was Doctors Without
Borders we've been friends for a decade
she actually speaks at the end of the
video thanks crystal
and we just felt because of the personal
connection and and because of you know
the way that they are showing up for the
most vulnerable people in our world
right now it felt like a natural choice
mm-hmm I love the list of collaborators
that you've got on this everybody you
know lending their voice was it an easy
thing for everyone like when you did you
contact everybody because I mean Julia
you've written songs for so many of
these people did you guys reach out to
them and say this is what we're gonna do
what was the process like well we're
just sort of watching our friends do
videos of our song and just like how can
we utilize this so that it helps people
and you know I'm not the kind of person
to ask for favors I've literally never
been that kind of person so the week
that we were reaching out to everybody I
had so no but but you know we got a lot
of people to do it and some people send
videos that day like you know just it
was really be able to see everybody want
to come together and want to do
something you know I feel like as
musicians you know we're not doctors
we're not saving the world the only way
we know how to how to help people is
through music and and you know be that
sort of release and escape for people
and a time that's really difficult so
just to see everybody you know band
together and do this together was truly
incredible I'm really grateful for all
the people that that wanted to do it
yeah mm-hmm who was like first when you
reached out who was like yes I'm on it
and you got that video from them like
right away I think Keith yeah Keith
Urban Keith Urban he was the first one
he liked he was a yes absolutely
whatever you need yeah
you fetch it I think you said it like an
hour later so fast yeah okay
he's amazing so given that you guys have
you said that in the beginning of this
you know you're putting a lot of
pressure on yourselves and now you're
kind of relaxing a bit more are there
collaborations that you guys are working
on that we can be looking forward to in
the future
I mean not for me no right now but yeah
I mean we've been writing a lot I'm not
sure there's any specific like feature
with any specific person but certainly a
lot of songs and a lot of ideas that
were passionate about it sure will turn
into something maybe it'll be with
friends maybe not who knows yeah what
does it look like when you guys are
creating songs I mean when you're just
in the process of putting something
together is it just you guys enjoying
what you do do you do it with the
purpose of oh maybe one day this is
something that we'll put out or is it
just kind of like play for you guys like
it kind of starts out as just you know
like a silly idea and then we're like oh
this could be something let's maybe
finish that need I don't I don't think
we we always have an end goal for it we
just we love to write songs and you know
I'm quarantine with one of my favorite
songwriters and I get to you know just
write songs with someone who I love to
every day so I ran around the planet and
the thing is about songs we love them we
love them very much so we're constantly
making little dumb songs and sometimes
little dumb melodies that we're seeing
while we're roaming around the house
turning to something good or sometimes
we'll have a conversation and one of us
will say something in the other and like
yeah or you know you'll say something
interesting to me and I'll be like okay
hold that thought you should write that
down
yeah that happens occasionally tennis
you've done it recently that a lot
sometimes it's so annoying
they'll just be trying to have a sincere
conversation with her a little like be
in the intense conversation and you'll
stop me mid candor to be like in each
verse verse
like it's not a verse baby I'm telling
you the truth you can't you can't help
yourself right yeah can we talk about
give it to you this is a the song yeah
was collaboration with the song land
right what is with the song all about
well actually I was telling Brian that
I'm pretty sure song land is the only
show that I've actually been a part of
where I felt useful because I mentioned
on the voice I've mentored on Idol but
like I don't know what I think about
myself I don't think with myself is like
this incredible singer so when I'm like
judging someone on their voice I just
feel like a fraud but when I'm like
sitting in a room with my colleagues and
we're just listening to songs it was
like oh this is this feels like home
this is this feels like me so being a
private process was really fun and I got
to listen to a bunch of different songs
and there was one in particular that I
just thought was really interesting and
we could we sort of just like took the
we took the production and just sort of
made a new song out of it and kind of
really helped me of that and just came
together really cool and really
effortlessly and I I love the show I
think it's so cool there's so many
people that want to know that it's an
awesome being a songwriter and that show
really does do it so perfectly that's
awesome
now I love that you guys are spending so
much time together and your engineer
making the best out of this situation
but when we're able to get out of here
we're able to go in and sort of live
maybe it's gonna be a new normal but a
version of normal that we can all accept
what do you guys want to do first well
you want a tour quite an escape room you
love a scale of escape I also just want
to give my friends irresponsibly long
honks yeah I want to go have a drink
with my friends and have dinner like sit
down and have dinner with people like I
miss I miss that a lot that's not nice